hornets get it back
here comes lamela ball with his hair on
fire
a windmill he and he had to windmill it
to get it to
go down the defender was there i don't
think he could have dumped it just right
out
all right let's do it again here comes
lamelo he's got miles with him
hayward oh hornets come alive
five quickies and philadelphia has to
call
timeout
[Applause]
oh bridges look at this
behind the back pass and yet i mean if
he tries to dump that maybe the sixers
get a hand on it
windmilling oh
[Music]
momentum took him out of that play
mcconnell didn't want to shoot it but
all he saw was daylight when he turned
and looked at the basket
bridges flips it over to the mellow
who's able to save it somehow
he's fallen out of bounds it threw a
beautiful pass to devonte
oh my goodness didn't see that coming
yeah tap the top of your head you just
made a highlight and i think sophonis
was involved la mello ball
with some serious yeast
[Music]
[Applause]
left side of your screen takes off right
around mcconnell and
flushes it down all over sabonis
boom that's a first as an nba player for
lamellar ball
[Music]
dumboya can't make the catch in traffic
lamella what a pass fights reggie's
welcome back lavello you just cannot
teach instincts like that was that with
his left hand
this pass battle of mello underhanded
i mean that's got to be timing touch
miles says i missed that
skilled chess pass from lamello gets
devonta in rhythm draggage left some
meat on the bone
here we go hornets have a chance get in
there yes
lamelo found rozier 80 feet away
and the hornets maybe regain a little
bit of momentum man
stop and start out
bound pass right on the money and
that is a good connection right there
look at that pass
easy finish lamelo ball have a half
how about that for awareness too terry
knew exactly how much time he had
and he gets it to fall that's a sharp
stick to the eye
again on saturday and then they'll
they're gonna
bold days off
sunday monday tuesday won't be back in
the short pants until wednesday
miles bridges all two-handed tomahawk
filthy pass there by lamelo
right around bouche oh my wow
he scratched his neck with the ball oh
he's
rozier cody zeller offensive rebound
[Applause]
bridges oh my god
get miles bridges attack
the shot blocker and little mellow oh my
word
just walk all over oh man
oh my goodness